こんにちははじめ立つようです皆さん是非をってことででしょうか
僕も子供の頃よく売れ語で言うとか会場を作った覚えがあります
今日はそんな英語をなるべくたくさん準備しました
はっはっは
どうでしたこのや俺は今まで行ってきたなかでこれ驚かずのレバーは見たことがないで
僕ちょっと夢だったんですけども
こんだけで子があれば
委員なんかもう全部レゴにできるんじゃねと思いまして
今なければ日きゅんではカフェとかも全然埋め尽くせると思うんでちょっと今日はこの
者医療のレールを使ってなるべく家を折る事だけにしてみたいと思ったわけなんです
けども
ここでカギになってくるのは
時間昔作ったことが届く知ってるんですよ作るのにメッツ時間がかかって多分一人だと
できないんですよと呼べる今日は素敵な助っ人を呼びしております敏じぃさん
tee
当然入っに入ってるさと税山居手伝ってもらってみんなの音を頼りに注ぎましょう
第二年前てくださいでちょっと家ん中全部で5にするのは多分
素人女じゃ難しいと思ったので今回さらにスペシャルなステップを呼びしております
どうぞ
[音楽]
高井さんの金子投げよろしくね純仁傘プロフェッショナルなのでお二人でおそれなら
みんなかを議論していきたいとおもいます
どうですか苦労を俯瞰するとこのローダといえていたよ
きついですかきつ
玄関だけどかどうですかあっいけません鍵が掛けしました
04人デイブレこのゲームをつくって来たーー
えっ私3グリーンないねぇ
早めっちゃ速いたのヴェーザー川だ
幸子ぐらいの時にもうこれが餃子れでは今日は社員ん
[音楽]
check 4あまりが辛くなってきましたねー
こういう形が複雑にん
こういうなんj マスタースラーも外壁を上に上げてきております
ぜひこれをフォローしようちょっと上げられんっ
それなー一般ございましたよ by kan
[音楽]
壁へと無くなっビクターのかなって思いますどうぞよい
ああ
美味しいなるっ
[音楽]
ブーブーんですけど
ですじゃブーブー言っ
[音楽]
3時間がとしました
3時間でけっ校
どうですかね60センチくらいですかねぇそうですねまだ折り返していただけないです
ね黒い
の果てさ船長なんじゃないですか本当に無理が待てよぞ
今4人で3時間半も頑張って神戸も行っておりませんでこのままだとちょっと市日方の
できなそうなんで
助っ人で後半呼びましたらどうぞ5人でちょっとニーズですね頑張っていこうと思い
ますけどさぁ
en
4日
って
ん
エロチェックをきましたねー
なか卯でしたなぁをソロで使ったのか
だったらていません
その2つの端に前に行ってきますけどいつのまにか立っています
はいとよる8時間経過しました高いところは結構
レバーできましたねー殺人はい
ソースない技を作ったんですねむーい
すごいすごいすごいだけどもうちょっとすかね
巨人や思えると思います
はいだけど皆さんもうほんとラスツインでネッコロまあ最後までがんばってきた車
シャア
ppap
完全に終盤ですついにアンチができております
え
初戦までもジェルで作業していただきありがとうございますこれ私のいえるのがわかり
ません
始めてからもうずう時間半が経過しておりますまあちょいです
ん
pou dou dou
チャンドクいっぱいやろってやるぜええとこ山田これやったんですね
や逃さずコフレまでを通ったらと思ってます
バーニーは4月の生物
止めなければたいいるじゃあまずコインで本気で動けなくてやったこのねこれらねこれ
相当すごいと思います見ていきます
パティスバーストこれすごいすごいと思いました
ブーブー言った夏
すごいなぁ両手が墨田2-8しました
もありますし
何度か村瀬ながらねっ
[音楽]
本当に
まずで素敵な玄関ができたのではないかと思っております
ちょってきたに一人で見てどんな逆算をするのか見ていきましょう
込めてくるとにアクションがもう泣きみたいなもんだすできた事に感謝だってよ
[音楽]
すごー
なにこれバッハすごいですねっ
すごいこれジェッタんか
ずーっとこれ時間がかかりせすごいっ
えっすごい日やクッション4 e 8 ea こういうすげー好きなんっすううっ
[音楽]
口どけど焼
オービター
ん
持って
醍醐嫌いですなっていた
で押すよねこれ迷路すかねぇ
おっくん
トゥン
walk さあどれくらい
恐れ
[笑い]
を無双に嬉しいぞねぇねぇ楽しいかな
[音楽]
え作ったスト滑っねぇいいねぇ知ってる
誓っていますなぁ
すごいねっていいですよ
はいというわけで玄関1名 all day 後でいっぱいにする突起に行ってみまし
たああどうでしたただただ
大変だっ医女かずっ
んですけれどもこういう遊び方もあるよっていう一例でございます
あとでも楽しかったですございました11時間を使えそうですねこうやって玄関でな鍋
バングルだけじゃなくても他にもいろんな楽しみ方があるみたいですね
そして今回バクシーはず3冊を cm に出させていただいている猫して消防署と空の
ポリス知れ基地が
27dec に新しく発売されましたーーー
[音楽]
もうこちらにあるんですけどもこちらです4でこちらの知り合いなんですけども米ゴス
ティーで起こる様々なトラブルを解決していくシリーズになっていましてこちらの消防
隊とカート部ポリスが家からを合わせてチームワークでレゴシティを守っていく
そんなシリーズになっていますこちらですねギミックがまたすごくてですね
調子とかもひかり
それのサイレンがあっ
聞かレース今どれ号すごいよ一つ濡らしてやって持っています
こっちに関しても水で飛びますからねあそしてそれぞれポリスはなんと薔薇シートに
そのから折れることもできるんです
ヒーローレスキュースター
を
スント6つかそしてなんと今回こちらの商品で
さと人さんとどっちが早くつくれるか対決もやりました
果たしてどちらがかっぱりでしょうか様子がこちらをご覧ください
動画な概要欄からも見れますので是非チェックしてみてください
対決のもちろんなんですけどもこの霊子めちゃくちゃかっこいいので皆さんも作ってみ
て下さい
そういうわけで大総括はみんなでレゴでざーん
[音楽]
me
ni
あっひっ